okay this is bill loosen from Stanford
University and I'd like to welcome all
of you from to the today's panel
discussion a virtual conference on the
National brain initiative and we have
myself plus three panelists today Terry
sinofsky from the Salk Institute emily
brown from MIT and justin sanchez who's
a program manager in the defense science
office at DARPA and so we are going to
each make statements of 10 or 12 minutes
and then we will entertain some question
answer and I thought we'd start this off
today by looking at a clip of President
Obama announcing the National brain
initiative at the White House last April
many times we hear things from
Washington you know and we think another
program what they're thinking up there
but I actually think the White House got
this right this time because this is a
field that's poised for revolution and
those of us who work in their science
understand that the field is changing
extremely rapidly right under our feet
and this is really appropriate time for
a national brain initiative we believe
so let's let's roll the clip of
President Obama and just let him open
the proceedings here today now as humans
we can identify galaxies light-years
away we can study particles smaller than
an atom but we still haven't unlocked
the mystery of the three pounds of
matter that sits between our ears so
there's this enormous mystery waiting to
be unlocked and the brain initiative
will change that by giving scientists
the tools they need to get a dynamic
picture of the brain in action and
better understand how we think and how
we learn and how we remember
and that knowledge could be will be
transformative so I think this was a
extremely eloquent speech those of you
who listen to all of it if you haven't
I'd suggest that you do so but a couple
of themes came through right there that
will be themes throughout our panel
discussion today giving scientists the
tools that they need and brain dynamics
understanding the brain in action and
function and my job here is opening
panel this is just to give you an
overview of the NIH brain working group
process this was a committee formed by
Francis Collins Cori Bargmann of the
Rockefeller University and I or chairs
of the committee and it was our mission
to to review the scientific evidence of
what the opportunities are currently and
say where we should actually put our
efforts as a nation and trying to unlock
the mysteries of the brain and here are
quotes from our charge that was given to
the committee by Francis Collins and the
NIH leadership and our charge said to
accelerate the development and
application of innovative technologies
to construct a dynamic picture of brain
function that integrates neural and
circuit activity over time and space so
there are those two themes of
technologies and dynamics coming through
again and the charge also told us to
build on neuroscience genetics physics
engineering informatics nanoscience
chemistry mathematics to catalyze an
interdisciplinary effort of
unprecedented scope so you can see that
this is not a modest charge this is
actually very ambitious and we were you
know properly I think awed by the charge
in front of us we decided here's here's
a map of our initial process we decided
that we did not have enough expertise on
our committee to do this by ourselves
and we conducted four workshops over the
spring and summer of 2013 on molecular
approaches to neuroscience human
neuroscience theory and computation and
Big Data large-scale recording and
structural biology and we had four
additional meetings over the summer all
over this Carmen
an interim report to the advisory
committee to the director of the NIH and
that interim committee that interim
report then was examined by people
neuroscientist and public across the
nation and in the interim the report we
identified as the primary focus of the
brain project a focus on circuits and
networks and basically we decided that
our central purpose was to map the
circuits of the brain measure the
fluctuating patterns of electrical and
chemical activity flowing within those
circuits so that's the dynamics part and
then understand how the dynamical
activity in the circuits actually
creates our unique cognitive and
behavioral capabilities so we boil this
down and sort of four kinds of maps of
them literally maps but one of them sort
of metaphorical map the very first most
important is cellular maps with
molecular components so this is
basically an atlas of cell types in the
brain we are all trying to understand
the cell types and brains this is the
basic parts list the components list
that the nervous system is made up the
second type is the second kind of map is
activity maps and much has been made
about the activity maps really trying to
understand the display of activity in
space and time as a nervous sectional
system actually functions during
behavior the third kind of map is
connectivity so this is the well-known
connect home and we can think about
connectomes at local ranges and alarm
ranges a fourth kind of map is a
functional map we're thinking here of
perturbations in the nervous system
we've had techniques for conserving this
system for decades but some of the most
powerful ones have just come online in
the last decade like optogenetics and
pharmacogenetics and these mapping
neural activity on behavior these
perturbation techniques are incredibly
important but then none of the
collection of data in these first four
categories will be understandable
without conceptual maps of the brain and
for that we need theory and computation
and understanding so we envision this as
an interdisciplinary effort or discovery
of fundamental
properties and principals insight into
circuits relevant to human brain
function and importantly disease and we
envision a major outcome it as being
acceleration of basic science medicine
and technology so we have several
principles that we think like the heart
of the brain project will lie on the
heart the brain project for the next
five to ten years one is that no
experimental systems are out of bounds
we want to use appropriate experimental
systems all kinds of animal models and
where appropriate be able to do i do
experiments and get good information in
human humans all the time respecting
appropriate ethical and clinical care
standards another principle is to cross
boundaries we envision toolmakers
working together with tool users
theorists working intimately with
experimentalists it's important to
integrate spatial and temporal scales
and understand how spatial scales from
molecules to synapses to circuits to
networks of circuits and all the way up
to behavior work together we want to
establish platforms for sharing data we
think it's a fundamental principle that
all data created by the brain project
should be public and available for other
people to use and analyze that this is
the way we will go forward faster we
feel like technology is not developed
for its own sake but it has to be
validated in real experimental systems
and then disseminated to the large
community of neuro scientists or else
it's to someone's private property it
doesn't do us really good and then a
final principle and when that we were
instructed this very carefully by the
NIH director is to consider the ethical
implications of neuroscience research
after this interim report appeared in
September of last year we got a lot of
feedback as you might imagine over the
succeeding months and our very first
sort of barrage of really good feedback
came at the society for neuroscience
meeting in November of 2013 in San Diego
and we had several forums for feedback
there we had an open society for
neuroscience panel discussion with the
leaders of several brain project in
several US agencies including an eye
NSF and DARPA and we had a report from
the European Commission as well Cori
Bargmann and I let a town hall with the
scientific community where anyone could
come and ask questions about brain and
make comments deliver feedback to us we
met with the neuroscience members of the
National Academy of Sciences and an all
morning session and received a lot of
valuable feedback there finally at the
end of the SFM meeting we had a meeting
of our working group where we had a
one-on-one sort of discussion with the
leadership of sfn and we had additional
presentation of future plans by NSF
DARPA HHMI Allen Brain Science Institute
as well as the Catholic Foundation and
finally we had a series of telephone
conferences and one-on-one discussions
with leaders of professional clinical
site societies during January of 2014 so
the next steps of the committee are the
big red letter date that we have out
there in front of us and you can see
I've got this in red letters on this
slide is to deliver the final report to
the advisory committee to the director
of NIH and our red letter date there is
June the 5th 2014 which just happens to
be my birthday happy birthday bill but
this this final report as opposed to the
previous the interim report will
emphasize medium and long term goals
critical technologies that have to be
developed we'll also have timelines in
there we'll have cost estimates and
we'll have deliverables so we actually
don't want this to be you know
airy-fairy bunch of scientists just kind
of out doing their thing whatever that
might be we really want specific goals
and deliverables that people can expect
out of brain initiative and then NIH
after our final report is delivered will
hold a major stakeholder meeting
probably sometime in the fall would be
my guess to coordinate national and
international effort so this is a
question that's on many people's mind
how does brain in the US relate to the
human project what's going on in Japan
how that Israel out what's Chaya doing
and I think NIH will be an ostp the
Office of Science and Technology at the
White House will be trying to coordinate
some of these international partnerships
and then there are also
brain initiative partners here within
the u.s. who will be certainly present
such a meeting you want the NIH all the
NIH leadership to be there
representatives of the Society for
Neuroscience representatives of clinical
societies and importantly patient
advocacy organizations as well so that
is sort of a thumbnail sketch a really
quick thumbnail sketch of our process
thus far these are the members of a
working group that you see in front of
you now two of the members of the NIH
working group are part of our panelists
today tere sanam ski and Henry Brown and
I am now going to turn and control of
this over to Terry and he will be the
next speaker let's see if I can figure
out exactly how to do that so I'm having
a I'm having a problem passing control
passing content control only is that
what I want Don could you send me a
message and other everything is grayed
out except for past content control only
do i do pass content control Terry is
your webcam connected ok I'll pastor I'm
getting a message now from emory brown
to passed away ok so we're going to go
to emory brown MIT rather than Terry
some now ski at the moment
so I'm going to bring my slides up here
there we go okay so it's a pleasure to
talk to as part of as one of the members
of the brain initiative and to give you
some idea of like what the work is we
hope to accomplish I'm going to talk
about two parts of the I'm going to talk
about two parts of the initiative one is
going to be about the importance of
using developing proper models mystical
techniques and data analysis approaches
and the second is going to be
specifically about human experimentation
and human research so if we accomplish
the goals of the brain initiative we
certainly are contar competently will
then one of the things that's going to
happen is just the practical reality
we're going to have a lot of data to
look at and having a lot of generating a
lot of data and not being able to turn
it into information would be a huge
problem if we don't address it up front
so one of the high priority areas for
research that we've identified for the
brain initiative will be to develop
methods models and computation that
allow us to try to get the maximal
amount of information extraction from
our data as its collected and for this
we realize an experimentalist will have
to collaborate with scientists from a
number of different areas in particular
statistics physics mathematics and
engineering and also computer science so
one of the things that I just want to
point out is what's really unique and
kind of exciting about neuroscience data
analysis so here's a little schema but
because the brain is dynamic
understandably neuroscience data are
dynamic and also it's multivariate and
sort of multi type okay so if you look
at this little scheme we may think of
ideas of how the brain works we do
experiments and then if the experiments
were just perfect then we'd be able to
just look at the data and see if the
results agreed with the models or the
abstract idea that we have
and that's often never the case and it's
going to be less and less the case as
data get to be more complex and these
are some illustrations of the type of
data that we're going to to be acquiring
neurophysiological data functional
magnetic resonance imaging data
electroencephalography magnetic magneto
cell filagra cognitive responses
behavioral data very rich Iran this is
only a small subset I'll say more about
that in just a second but the key idea
is we have to think formerly of how we
go back from experiments with
appropriate statistical methods and
computational tools and modeling to see
if the idea is that we developed in our
abstract models and our hypotheses and
our experiments are born out for our
experiments are actually born out by the
data so this loop is an iteration which
we've planted which ideally we should
take over and over again and by thinking
very critically about them data analysis
methods we want to put ourselves in a
position so that this happens as
efficiently as possible so I want to
just give you a few examples so these
are this is just a slide which is
designed to illustrate this the Richard
array of data that are currently
available on in neuroscience so this is
just a raster plot of neurons from the
human brain collected in this case under
anesthesia and this is an array of 129
neurons on the left side you see a very
large pattern each row is the spiking
activity of one neuron and you can see
what the neurons were doing and at this
point here will you see the red line
that's where the anesthetic was given
and you can see how the effect changed
what's so interesting about this is
these are actually neurons from a human
brain which I'll say a little bit more
about later and we're actually seeing
how they change under anesthesia this is
an illustration of functional magnetic
resonance imaging it's probably one of
the workhorses certainly for human
neuroscience and trying to figure out
what's happening in the brain there
another illustration is simple
behavioral data the red bow to hear this
is animal learning a task it's red
meaning it's getting it wrong all the
sudden starts to get it right and the
zeroes which are the red turn into ones
which are over here glue another
illustration is just my needle
encephalograph II and electrons a
photography where we make surface
recordings
on the scalp and then what we try to do
is in her web parts of the brain are
active as a consequence and then here we
have diffused optical tomography diffuse
optical tomography is a technique which
we use to image what's actually
happening inside the brain along with
calcium imaging so this is just a small
subset of the types of data that are
going to be produced by the brain
initiative and their many many many more
so it's got to be very it's very clear
that one important thing that must
transcribes we have to work starting now
on the method that will help us get the
most information possible from the data
so I wanted to say a few more a few
words about human experimentation
because ultimately among other things
one of the reasons that we're studying
the brain is so we can improve human
health in particular come up with better
therapies for a wide range of
neurological and neuropsychiatric
disorders realizing this we're going to
be building tools but we want to
certainly build not only the tools but
the mechanism to make it possible for us
to collect human data and then also try
to extract as much information as
possible all understandably with the
utmost of ethical standards and right
now there's a lot of human
experimentation which is being done
because patients are coming for therapy
such as epilepsy surgery or they're
having deep brain stimulators implanted
to treat obsessive-compulsive disorders
or perhaps depression or to treat
Parkinson's disease and as a consequence
this provides unique opportunity to at
the same time learn about directly how
the human brain functions having this
transpire requires special teams of
larger than individuals
multidisciplinary neurologists no
surgeon psychiatrists psychologists
engineers computer scientists
anesthesiologist because these resources
are so substantial one of the things we
want to make sure that where it's
possible that we can enable this as a
consequence of the the work being done
the brain initiative I thought I would
just give you a few it's maybe three
examples of sorts of things that were
able to learn I sort of see as a
consequence of this type of work so
here's an illustration from some of our
own research which reflects
anesthesiology and it just schematically
shows you how we're able to integrate
the findings from basic science work
with clinical research and actually get
some new insights about how the brain
might work under anesthesia this is a
schema just to say we've had ideas for a
number of years about how the drugs may
work in different circuits we can
actually measure those in terms of EEG
this is a spectrogram from the patient
is actually under anesthesia with the
help of our modeling colleagues like
Nancy coppell we can develop models that
help us understand how these
oscillations may come about and one of
the signature features of being under
anesthesia is having very very profound
oscillations that encompass large parts
of the brain and this is just an
illustration of that this encompasses
like that the whole front of the head
when someone is in profiling
anesthetized and it's and it's not just
an arbitrary frequency for ten Hertz and
then this is just to illustrate that
here we're actually recording from
patients as they've gone under
anesthesia this is the patient is having
epilepsy surgery because when they have
epilepsy surgery and the electrodes
implanted to locate the focus where the
epilepsy may be the source of the the
the source of the epileptic seizure they
come to have that removed Lola need
anesthesia so we can record and see what
the brain does and it's very easy to see
in this diagram that one of the things
the brain does is generating the
anesthetic induces very very large slow
oscillations and actually just actually
govern when the neurons can and cannot
spike so this is something we would have
no way of knowing without having the
good fortune of collaborating with our
neural surgical colleagues and erotic
neurological colleagues at Mass General
to allow us to do this experiments to do
sort of recording and here are two other
illustrations this shows you human a
patient having an epileptic seizure here
you can see the seizure activity here on
Aug and it stops abruptly this is work
which is being done by stood cash and a
straw
hospital and this is just to illustrate
that one of the things that they're
working on is not only just recording us
but actually trying to come up with a
bottle but help us really understand
it's very rich and important array of
data and as a final illustration this is
very exciting work which is done by Lee
hofburg and John Donahue at Brown
University as we really come to
understand the brain perhaps one of the
things that we can do we can use it we
can help restore function to patients
that have had brain injuries and this is
a lady who is quadriplegic and one of
the amazing things that we and John have
been able to do is to capture her neural
signals from her thoughts of the
movement area in the brain and have her
control of robotic arm so here the
robotic arm has 0 as a drinking
apparatus in it she's thinking about
having our move over it moves over under
her control because she's thinking about
it it brings it to her she's able to
take a jerk take a drink and then she
puts it back down so in some sense this
is kind of the ultimate if you would and
understanding the brain knowing how the
various areas function then being able
to capture that information
appropriately effectively in real time
and then design a therapy in this case
of robotic arm or could be other types
of therapies which then enables this
person to recover a function that she
had actually lost so these are the types
of exciting things that we see is coming
into the future here and so now I'm
going to pass on to my colleague i'm
terry sandowski and i can tell you about
some of the next paper you have some of
the other aspects
okay first of all I want to welcome
everybody on the webcast and I want to
start with the goal of the brain
initiative which is to develop
innovative neurotechnologies and as
Emery pointed out these new technologies
as they come online are going to give us
unprecedented amounts of data to analyze
and I want to start out by showing you a
remarkable video of a larval zebrafish
brain now the zebrafish has a relatively
small brain about a hundred thousand
neurons and it's transparent and what
this means is that we can use optical
techniques to view activity in all of
the neurons and I'm going to show you a
video of the larval zebrafish brain in
which are we a group at janelia farm
howard hughes medical institute of nisha
errands was able to record from over
eighty percent of the neurons in the
brain as 80,000 neurons and this is
something that no scientists until
recently could only dream about what
you're going to see now is twinkling and
the twinkling stars that you'll see our
single neurons and when they light up
their active so if we could run that
video of the zebrafish brain
you
okay I think that what you saw there
were actually two videos and the first
video was a reconstruction of a
particular neuron in the hippocampus of
a rat and the second video was a
zebrafish and it shows you two different
scales vastly different scales the first
one a way that we can actually go down
almost like a computational microscope
and zoom in on single neurons and and
what's inside of them what you saw was a
piece of a pyramidal cell you saw
synapses but in the zebrafish brain what
you saw was something that is really
quite remarkable which is the the the
blinking on and off which is spontaneous
activity the zebrafish was immobilized
this is really quite remarkable as a
triumph or technique but there's a
problem which is that we don't know what
we're looking at what does all that
activity mean just imagine what it was
like to look up at the stars we're in
the same position as our ancestors many
many years ago looking up at the stars
and wondering what was up there that
what they what they thought they saw was
a crystal sphere surrounding their there
of central location in the universe but
as you can see in this would cut for the
middle ages that all changed new
instruments like telescopes were
invented just as today new microscopes
are being invented to look into brain
activity but in astronomy the real
breakthrough came when new theories were
created first by Copernicus of the
theory that the planets went around the
Sun and second a Newton's theory of
gravity which allowed us to predict the
orbits of the planets what's missing
from the picture today is a theory that
will let us explain the meaning of all
the signals that we see in the brain the
brain weighs only two percent of the
body weight but it consumes twenty
percent of the power it's an enormous
the a powerful computational device that
we're just beginning to understand the
brain is tasked with the keeping track
of all the information that is coming in
through our senses and to accumulate
that information over a lifetime and to
help us survive to find food to find
mates blame theories are going to have
to account for halt all that information
how is it remembered how is it used how
our decisions made now it makes us
really difficult and this slide
illustrates the many levels of
investigation that we can study the
brain app from the molecular at the very
bottom to the entire central nervous
system at the very top we have
techniques like brain imaging at the
very top which gives us a global picture
of the brain which unfortunately at the
moment has relatively low spatial and
temporal resolution but very important
for giving us an overall picture at the
bottom we can probe the activity of
single neurons and we know that if for
example in the cortex there's ten
billion neurons we can record from a few
of them at a time but this is the drop
in the bucket so we clearly need to
improve the number of neurons it can
record from and in the brain initiative
we hope that the techniques that will
become available will allow us to record
from millions of neurons and that will
give us a much better picture what's
happening in particular parts of the
brain now another thing that is is going
to help us enormously is computer models
so computers are really helping us both
to store data analyze it but also to
come up with very detailed dynamical
models of what's going on inside of
neurons and activity patterns and
networks of neurons and this gives us
new ideas we can go back to the lab and
test them this will give us insights
perhaps that we wouldn't have otherwise
now finally I want to show you a picture
here this is over a hundred years ago
bagni Cahal the great
Spanish neuroanatomist developed and
used a technique called the Golgi stain
that gave us a very sharp picture of
single neurons and as you can see here a
pyramidal cell when the cerebral cortex
has these beautiful dendritic arbors and
which synapses are formed and of coming
out the bottom and axon which connects
up to other neurons now this is a
beautiful stained but it gives us a
misleading picture because it shows an
isolated neuron the reality is that all
the neurons are jam-packed and what we
can do now using Kinect omics is to be
able to reconstruct the patterns of
activity between all the neurons and
densely packed that you saw in the first
movie now finally okay so I'll just like
to thank everybody for four also
attending this meeting so I'm looking at
the number of attendees here and given
that there are hundreds and hundreds of
people online that really shows the
intense interest and excitement around
this international effort and brain
sciences so today I'd like to introduce
DARPA's perspective and in particular
the science of perspective on brain
function research related to the
president's brain initiative so from
DARPA's perspective you know we're
really trying to change the way we think
about science and the way that we do
science related to brain function
research our efforts are extremely
mission-driven we don't do science just
for the sake of doing sighs we decides
for a purpose we try to focus our
efforts such that capabilities and
knowledge become fused together in order
to deliver these new capabilities if you
kind of take a broad look at what's
going on right now you can see that the
field is changing into to research as
focusing on systems of neurons that is
being interface with technology and this
really opens up this
new perspective of hybrid biological
computational approaches that can really
look at how you know the brain is
processing information in real time and
interacting back within with the
environment now as you heard from the
previous speakers we're very interested
in understanding the real-time neural
dynamics of these systems as they
interface not only with the body other
parts of the brain but also back with
the environment and as we build more
deeper knowledge in these areas we
really think that this is going to lead
to precision therapy about dysfunction
and injury of the brain so ultimately
though if we want to achieve these high
level goals we need to again change our
approach to doing this so this really
means tuning into the hierarchical
organization of the brain as tarea just
stated and then thinking about
capabilities that translate the local
behaviors into more systems based
observation of the brain so this is an
area that we also feel very strongly
about traditionally neuroscience
research is very siloed right there are
research laboratories internationally
that look at their own particular part
of the brain and that's kind of the end
of the story as we move to more
complicated problems we need to
synergize those systems of the brain to
really understand this organ right it's
unlike any other organ of the body it's
a system is hierarchical and it's
dynamic in nature as we put all of those
pieces together though again we are dark
was really looking at these task
oriented investments and that could be
in the areas of restoring function
exploring new mechanisms of brain
function and then ultimately making
investments to deliver new technologies
that enable us to discover new aspect of
the brain and you know we're making
investments in a lot of areas these
could be prosthetic control could be
memory it could be even neuropsychiatric
relation i'm going to show a few
examples of that moving forward here in
terms of the mechanisms though we're
thinking about adaptation adaptation and
plasticity learning
even the causal relationships amongst
those elements in the hierarchy and so
as we progress through all of this one
of our highest priorities is
transitioning our findings back to
injured individuals who can really
benefit from the knowledge such that
these technologies restore function and
quality back to their life now with
those ideas in mind let's let me give
you a few examples of how DARPA's really
navigated this space thus far and the
first example I like to just show you is
in the area of motor neural interfaces
or brain machine interfaces restoring
near natural let's say arm control back
to people that have been injured our
efforts in this area actually started in
the early 2000s with the brain machine
interface program and later the hand
program and this approach you know for
up for understanding the brain of people
back at that time we're saying it is it
even possible to interface technology
with a brain and to enable somebody to
think about controlling a prosthetic
device just with their own neural
activity and since there was so much
uncertainty at the time we got started
very early in non-human primate work and
show that it indeed was possible but the
really exciting part about you know
getting those fundamentals in primates
and then taking a very focused approach
for doing science is that we transition
that technology to humans in the
revolutionising prosthetics program so
if you look at on the right side of this
slide here 2006 you know we made our
foray into human work now that's only a
handful of years between the discovery
of the possibilities of doing this kind
of work and the actual deployment of
that kind of work in human subject so it
really shows how doing very focused okis
science bringing technology and
knowledge together can yield very
profound changes in our understanding of
the brain and very profound deliverables
back to society we are continuing our
mission and in these kinds of areas but
we're expanding the capabilities and
areas of brain function that we're
interested in a new program that we're
just getting off the ground right
now is called the RAM program restoring
active memory and the vision for this
program is to develop neural prosthetics
for memory recovery and human patients
with brain injury dysfunction as many of
you know our main constituents at dark
our military personnel that have
undergone injury and many of them
sustained traumatic brain injuries has
been over 300,000 of those in just the
recent years so we're trying to develop
new technologies to get these people
back to a better quality of life now the
RAM program the way that it is
structured you know it took a few cues
from that neural prosthesis efforts that
we had very early on we actually had a
previous program called the remind
program that showed memory prosthetics
and animal subjects were feasible memory
declarative kinds of memories could be
restored in animal subjects and again
with that fundamental knowledge we asked
the question well can we take that
knowledge and really try to transition
it to humans and that's what the ramp
program is all about can we develop a
neural prosthetic technologies that can
sense that can model and can stimulate
the specific memory regions of the brain
to restore declarative memory and it's
extremely exciting time there are many
discoveries to be had in this area and
we're really looking forward to getting
started on that rowing program now in in
true DARPA fashion do we just stop there
with these kind of elemental aspects of
brain function so again I've told you
about motor control told you about
memory restoration but what about these
more complicated aspects of brain
function the ones that really are higher
order kinds of function neuropsychiatric
kinds of disorders that truly tap into
these systems of neurons and you know
the kinds of functions and disorders
that we're thinking about now our
depression PTSD anxiety disorder
borderline personality disorder maybe
even pain or addiction right we know
that these conditions affect many
different sub circuits of the brain
and because we had these fundamental
pieces of knowledge and fundamental
technologies interface of the brain
we're making continued investments into
more sophisticated problems and we have
a program called subnet systems based
neuro technology for emerging therapy
that is really going to push upon these
these aspects and the vision for this
program is to develop new neural
interfaces to measure how systems
disorders manifest in the brain and to
precisely deliver therapy to humans with
neuropsychiatric and neurologic diseases
again the approach is you know very
similar in the neural prosthetic domain
develop a device that can sense from
these sub circuits of the brain can
model the information in those sub
circuits and can deliver some sort of
precise therapy in a closed loop
real-time kind of a fashion now why are
we also making this you know this
investment from a societal perspective
if you look at that statement at the
bottom ten percent of the 22 million
veterans and you have received treatment
for mental health or substance abuse
issue this is a huge problem not only
affecting military personnel but also
broader aspects of society so we think
that we're going to have great returns
back in terms of the knowledge of the
brain as well as the clinical therapies
now just to take a little bit of a
deeper dive into this concept and you
know this approach will dovetail very
nicely with what Terry just mentioned if
we look at the state of the art right
now in terms of dealing with system
based disorders of the brain so take for
example a neuropsychiatric disorder the
best that your clinician or your patient
can do right now is you know potentially
lay out on the couch right talk about
your issues and then that clinician can
present to you either a a drug rights of
pharmacotherapy or they can suggest some
kind of surgery but the feedback cycle
of this kind of interaction is very slow
if not you know ever right you go when
you see the physician they give you some
things you hope for the best we want to
completely change the game on this we
want to be able to tap into multiple
levels of that hierarchy exploit really
what is known about the hierarchy
deliver those precise kinds of therapies
and if we have that new interface to the
brain and we can engage the brain at
multiple levels abstraction in a closed
loop real-time feedback we can do what
is really shown on the right side of
this slide we can empower physicians to
use knowledge based approaches to
understanding and treating the brain
devices of this type don't exist today
DARPA is making investments to develop
these kinds of devices and we really
think that is going to produce a new
understanding and new approach for for
treating these very complex kinds of
disorders so we're extremely excited
about the subnets program and are poised
to actually get started on that the last
kind of comments I would like to share
with you today to wrap up is that you
know DARPA really understands and is
very proactive in terms of the societal
implications of these new technologies
and these new concepts you know
leading-edge technology and uncovers
these new questions right ethical legal
social you know safety security policy
kinds of questions and we have assembled
a terrific team to to help provide
feedback on these issues we really feel
that it's DARPA's role and mission to
get into these uncharted territories you
know it's really keeping the country
prepared in terms of our knowledge of
brain science and what it really means
for the broader aspects of society and
we are engaging as many people as
possible to provide information on all
of this and again this is extremely
exciting time for brain science research
because we're going to learn so much
about what this means for the future and
we're working hard at trying to uncover
those problems so speaking about the
future let's just do a few projections
here okay so if we really look at today
you know a lot of the discussion has
been focused around exploring new
scientific approaches which human
participants the revolutionising
prosthetics the ramp program the subnets
programs are all really human based so
we are going to learn a lot about this
we're going to be developing new tools
for discovery and in an
ultimately using those tools to develop
that mechanistic understanding not
really projected over the near horizon
let's say five years for example this is
a course of these programs that we will
be able to provide new aspects of
therapeutic relief to these populations
I really also think we'll be able to
examine how neuronal behavior can direct
and inform other systems and then
ultimately this information can help us
to choose new therapeutic targets for
the future deepening our understanding
of brain function in the mid term if we
thinking kind of ten years out you know
I think that the challenge for the the
community as a whole is how to take
these kind of technologies that are
affecting people with disabilities and
then you know considering the broader
societal impacts right how can these
kinds of technologies affect everyday
life you know I think this is a really
profound aspect of this kind of work
right we're making huge investments in
this area but how does it really come
back to the everyday person you know on
the street you know how does neuro
technology in form and transform our
lives so you know I if I had one wish
and all of this is that we can use this
this knowledge in this new technology to
really transform therapies for the
broader aspects of the populations
health right moving our efforts and our
capabilities to better brain health I
think is going to be tremendously
beneficial to our society as a whole so
I'm extremely excited to be a part of
this and you know I'd like to echo you
know a lot of the statements that are
out there this is an all-hands-on-deck
effort to make these concepts of reality
so we want to see the best ideas the
best science helping to move our efforts
forward into the future so thank you so
much
okay great so thank you Terry and Emery
and Justin and we have a few minutes
left now for QA and I've got a few
questions up here that have come in one
of the ones that I would like to try to
just address right off the bat is a
question that came in how would the
brain mapping at the molecular level be
translated into higher order structure
and ultimately function what would be
the approaches and tools to achieve
those so I really want to make this
point I'm a kind of assistance counting
myself most of you who know me but the
molecular level and genetic level is
incredibly important to this entire
effort the kinds of sensors that we have
that you saw in a zebrafish movie that
are allowing us to report from thousands
of neurons at a time that's all be too
heavy molecular engineering to make
those calcium sensors as good as
possible our new perturbation
technologies for optogenetics all comes
from molecular and cellular level
research ultimately our access to
different cell types in the brain and
being able to tune and tweak circuits
very specifically depends on genetic
access to be cell types so so the
molecular and genetic levels underlie
and are crucial to the entire brain
effort another question that has come in
here that I think it's on a lot of
people's mind and i'm going to ask kelly
sadowski to address this question the
question says when it comes to data
sharing and dissemination of technology
is there a plan or structure in place to
allow a new technology and I'm going to
pass this to Terry and see if he can say
some words about about about this
technology although Terry I don't
actually see again we've lost full
control on you so maybe what we'll do is
in fact go to a different question okay
going to pass to Emory Emory I'm going
to ask you a question about what would
be the crucial technologies and tools to
link neural activity to cognition and
behavior in humans that's one of the
questions that has come into our past
this control to Emory bear
so thanks Bill I heard just sort of the
last part of the the question our
question just because of the audio
difficulties here but but just speaking
specifically about the types of things
that we hope to see like in the human
studies i mean i can tell you coming out
of the work which will which will be
delivered by the brain initiative for
human studies in health human health i
can tell you as a clinician an
anesthesiologist working in academic
environment what we think about all the
time is because we're constantly taking
care of patients is how can we make this
better and one of the things like in the
field of anesthesiologists gonna enable
on a few geology tremendously to be a
better clinical neuroscience discipline
is taking advantage of the work which
will come out of the initiative just as
one illustration right now it's almost a
given that twenty to thirty percent of
patients that are having anesthesia will
have difficulty recognizance and the
likelihood of this gets to be worse once
we as we get older and also we're very
concerned about it the effects that
anesthetics might have on the developing
brain and children what this actually
means is that we need new approaches and
without having a fundamental
neuroscience understanding you know
using animal systems and then modeling
and better data analysis will never get
there so this is a tremendous
opportunity I think for for for
anesthesiology particular but then you
could replace anesthesiology with any
other area sort of disorder whether it's
the neuropsychiatric and neurological
disorders as I'm Justin was talking
about neurodegenerative disorders being
able to really understand how the
circuits were and eventually design
therapy with then control them so we can
restore normal function I think is going
to be a recurrent paradigm through this
initiative and it's part of the I think
a major part of the excitement of what
we're seeing so I'll turn control back
over to Bill
okay thanks and we appreciate that so
there are some more questions that are
rolling in here I hardly know how to
pick them one question is can cognition
be fully understood that comes from mr.
crane guests laugh at clacking
University and you know this is a grand
challenge this is one of the things that
we all want to know I have no idea
whether cognition in the end can be
fully understood i think that many
aspects of conduct cognition will be
understood in many aspects of behavior
of where we understood with this whole
business of the human brain trying to
understand itself is a grand challenge
and i certainly think there is a ton of
the progress that you can make but how
how far will get with that how quickly i
don't know there is an interesting
question here that I'm going to ask all
of the panelists to comment on what
would be reasonable to achieve within
the first five to ten years that's a
really that's a really interesting
question about what could deliverables
actually be and you know for me I would
I would pick one like I would like to
have some some animal we're all of these
new techniques are integrated where we
can record from every neuron during
natural behaviors several natural
behaviors for some period of time and we
know the full connector MCMAP of how all
those neurons are connected together and
really importantly and crucially we
can't we have a theory about how these
neurons are working together to produce
behavior so I would like to I would my
dream would be to have some successful
we actually integrate comic comics and
activity and theory orleans
understanding some aspect in behavior
and cognition but i'm going to turn
control over to Justin right now and I
want to ask Justin how he would respond
to this what would be reasonable
she'd within the first in 5-10 years
Justin or what's half okay it looks like
it's back to me so it's and it looks
like Justin had to go so I'm gonna I'm
gonna pass control to Justin heavy go so
let's see I guess I'm on the air so bill
asked what can we expect to achieve in
the next five years you know I think the
zebrafish gave us a a taste of what the
future is like and I think that we
should be able to understand some of the
basic systems if we can in the very same
zebrafish if we can record all that
activity and be able to work out the
entire wiring diagram of the zebrafish
crane that's a tall order using Kinect
omics and then do that a log we are
studying the behavior while the
zebrafish is trying to swim while it's
reacting to the sensory input I think
that in five years we should be able to
put together to integrate the recordings
the connections and then to create a
very detailed understanding of the
circuits and and model of the the
information flowing to the circus okay
and I would actually like to go if I can
get them I'd like to go to Emory and
have Emily reflect respond to that
question so um again I because of audio
difficulties I've had difficulty hearing
that just just the last question but if
I think into the future I think that
there is a tremendous amount which is
going to transpire I think in the near
term we're going to learn
a lot more just basic information about
how various parts of the brain function
at different levels and this was just
going to open up our eyes tremendously
if you think about it as recently as
only 20 years ago high fraction
neuroscience is done by recording one
year on at a time and now we're looking
at the capability of recording many
neurons at the same time what I like
about the brain initiative is that we're
going to place emphasis on not only not
only conducting those recordings but
also on trying to extract as much
information as possible from those
recordings and as I mentioned earlier
this is not a requirement to
disciplinary approach and this this will
hopefully change the culture of
neuroscience we will really have to work
in teams to to sort this out and I think
that will see this cultural change occur
as we get more and more into this
process and I think that it's going to
be the sharing of information and the
sharing of collaborations that is going
to really enable us to accomplish the
goals of developing tools that then
allow us to not only understand the
brain that then the consequence of being
able to control the repair make than
other lives of many many patients
patients better so I see this if you
want a car with a sort of change in
sociology which we're trying to foster
through the initiative as being a big
thing which will come out of it and in
particular this will be really really
key for human neuroscience where we
can't begin to collect and spectacle
sorts of information that we need if we
don't operate in teams so I'll pass
control back to back to our moderator
bill
so i would i would add another thing
that it should be very achievable in the
next five years we ought to be see
expensive atlases of cell types and
extensive atlases of at least medium
scale connections in a variety of brains
so sometimes is really important this is
this is something that it's it's the
parts listing brain we know there are
the 50 cell types in a retina getting
active genetic access to the various
cell types and actually being able to
manipulate them independently of each
other is critical and this is a thing
where I think the technology exists
right now and putting an atlas of cell
types in front of people and getting
people tools to access different cell
types this is going to benefit not only
the brain initiative but it's going to
benefit our clinical research it's going
to go to anyone who does any kind of
research on the nervous system and I
think that's something that's definitely
achievable starting in animals but
moving into humans over the next five to
ten years something that I think we can
all really look forward to there's a
there's a interesting there are several
interesting questions here are there any
initiatives to address the problem of
Alzheimer's and memory loss and this is
something that's on a lot of our minds
it's on my mind I'm age 62 this is not a
trivial question to me and I think that
brain initiative itself is not
specifically disease related but it's
important to know that we are trying to
put in place tools that will help us
address all diseases like Alzheimer's
and memory loss it's also important to
realize that the brain initiative is
spending about 100 million dollars in
the first year and this compares to a
total of five point two billion of NIH
spending are alone on neuro biologically
related problems and including a very
large chunk of money on programs
directly related to Alzheimer's and
memory loss and what we want brain to be
as act like an amplifier with critical
technologies in place a critical need
information in place about the basic
function of the brain
that will then amplify the entire five
billion dollar investment and make that
five billion dollar is worth a lot more
because the scientists who work on the
problems of Alzheimer's and memory loss
have more tools at their disposal there
is another interesting question here
what mechanisms exists for older
established investigators in other areas
to join the mission and I will try to
pass control over 2 i'll see if i can
pass control over the teres nasty if
he's still here i know that the group
that he was part of cares a lot about
attracting established investigators
Merle exact areas off the air again so
I'll just I'll just try to answer that
more one of the insights of the brain
committee or one of the things that the
brain committee feels very very strongly
about is that as Justin Sanchez said
this is an all-hands-on-deck effort and
we really need people in Decatur from
all fields the brain is no longer just a
problem in biology if it ever was it is
now a problem in theory it's a problem
in computation it's probably data
handling it's problem in chemistry and
it's a problem in psychology and we have
got to have people from all of those
fields in so there will be mechanisms
especially we need people to come in
from Statistics because we are having
these large data strings that we just
don't understand very well yet so we
need people new people new talent from
statistics and new people and new talent
from theory and computation to help us
understand the data and I think that
there will be roots that people we need
people from Electrical Engineering who
can help us do better signal processing
and build us better devices to get
microscopic and micro scale and
nanoscale devices into the brain and
communicate them within wirelessly so
that the current systems we have which
seem so cumbersome can be improved and
gets next generation so there
there will be lots of opportunities I
think for people to for people to work
on this I'll see that Terry's back on
Terry there's a question here about
about data sharing and uh if there are
actual initiatives going on to make data
available and what we think about data
sharing and I'm going to pass through
sharing on them yes one of the
challenges that we have right now is a
not a technical one is a sociological
one the way that experiments are done in
labs is that data are collected
typically by students and postdocs and
then the data are analyzed and then
papers are written and then the data
languishes on a computer and and it
never sees the light of day we in the
brain initiative there's going to be an
effort to make the data available to
other scientists that is to say part of
the infrastructure that will be
developed will be a central file server
that will allow a neuroscientist and
others to pass their data on and this is
very important because new analytic
techniques are being developed every day
for analyzing data and that will allow
us to reanalyze old data and compare it
to new data coming in the same way for
example that astronomers have access to
archival data from the Hubble Space
Telescope which are being used to probe
the very early stages of the universe
after the Big Bang and this is something
that is going to take some effort by no
scientist to change habits it's it's
something though that will I think I
have a huge impact on the future of the
field in the same way that for example
having genomics databases has really had
a big impact on molecular genetics I'll
pass now back to Bill okay so we are now
over our allotted hour slightly and we
will draw this to a close we have a lot
of other good questions that could be
here and be answered and lead to lots of
fruitful discussion but I want to thank
all of the listeners and viewers for
being with us today and I hope we've at
least giving you a little taste of the
brain initiative and what it is at the
moment and what it can be for the nation
in the future and I would just like to
say you know again but I started with is
that I think the country has a really
unusual opportunity I think that this is
an area of science due to the new
technologies that have come online
that's poised for just extraordinarily
rapid growth and has extraordinary
promise for helping us understand as
President Obama said who we are as
humans and for helping us to address a
lot of really insidious neurological
diseases and I think this will have an
economic benefit I think that it in
entire companies and economy will grow
up around the knee discoveries that are
going to come out of brain science and
those companies and those jobs are going
to be in places where the discoveries
are being made and it's a critically
important time for the United States can
make a commitment that we are going to
be the place where these discoveries are
made so for all of you listening no
matter what field you in there's a place
for you here and for young people
especially this is a great way I think
to spend a career so we'll sign off now
and thank you so much for listening
goodbye